[Applause]
Pete Davidson and Chase Suey wonders
pack on the PDA at an amusement park and
it's kinda giving us Deja Vu you just
gotta roll with it seems the two's
latest display seemingly confirms their
romance as they spent the day together
at Universal Studios Hollywood check out
Pete and Chase holding hands as they
walk through the park and at one point
exchange kisses on an escalator
[Music]
foreign
yeah Pete and Chase also had some fun as
they rode a roller coaster totally
screaming their lungs out and it seems
the actor is all for the Thrills because
this isn't the first time Pete's taken a
love interest to a theme park the
comedian first sparked relationship
rumors with his ex Kim Kardashian when
they were spotted holding hands on a
roller coaster at Knott's Berry Farm
yeah so Pete and Chase's date looks all
too familiar I've been fortunate enough
to have some great relationships and you
know uh honesty is always really
important of course Pete has moved on
since Kim and as far as he and Chase go
their relationship status is still TBD
but a source did tell ET the pair like
each other a lot and have been spending
a lot of time together
oh what is she doing here oh Pete and
Chase co-starred in the 2022 film bodies
bodies bodies where's Max he's not
responding my text
s
rumors about the could be couple first
sparked last month when the pair was
spotted at a New York Rangers game at
Madison Square Garden with their other
bodies bodies bodies co-star Rachel
Senate our source says Pete and Chase
are both funny so they laugh a lot
together adding their connection is
natural Pete likes that chase is down to
earth and cool
[Applause]
yeah seems safe to say things are going
pretty well between the two
[Music]